Many actors look back on certain movies without
fondness, thanks to on-set problems, disappointing
scripts, or any number of other problems.
Here are just a few who regretted some of
their roles, movies, and decisions.
The Help told the story of several maids and
the families they worked for in 1960s Mississippi.
Starring a packed cast of talented actresses
including Viola Davis, Octavia Spencer, and
Emma Stone, the film chronicled a white woman's
mission to publish a book told from the perspective
of Mississippi maids.
Even though Davis received her second Oscar
nomination for the role, she has since admitted
that she has reservations about her role in
The Help.
Davis has never been shy about speaking her
mind, and for a film that was supposed to
support those without a voice, she eventually
decided that it fell short.
The whole experience seems best summed up
by her response to Empire when asked about
what it was like to wear a fat suit:
"I like playing someone other than myself.
It's only in hindsight that I go 'oh God,
why did I do that?'"
Anyone who's ever opened a newspaper is familiar
with Garfield, a surly orange cat who loves
lasagna and hates Mondays.
Most avid moviegoers are familiar with Bill
Murray, the comedy legend who starred in famous
films like Ghostbusters, Caddyshack, and Groundhog's
Day.
When Garfield: The Movie was released in 2004,
it baffled Murray's fans as to why the normally
picky actor chose Garfield as one of his projects.
As it turned out, Murray apparently assumed
that the writer of the film, Joel Cohen, was
one half of writer-director duo the Coen brothers,
and Murray wanted to appear in one of their
films.
"You know, I think I had a nightmare like
this once.”
The Fifty Shades book series became international
bestsellers, so popular that it basically
guaranteed an eventual movie adaptation.
Once it was unsurprisingly announced, Jamie
Dornan and Dakota Johnson beat off stiff competition
to play the leads.
That doesn't mean they were happy with their
success, though.
Dornan notably hated the entire series and
was fairly unsubtle about the entire thing—even
while on a promotional tour for the final
movie, Dornan couldn't resist complaining
about watching the final cut to Jimmy Kimmel:
"By the end, I'm literally watching it like
this.
I can't bear it."
Dakota Johnson was only slightly more subtle
about how much she didn't enjoy having to
act in the movies—or having to pretend to
be close to Dornan.
While promoting Fifty Shades Darker, she told
Today:
"I think we were kind of forced into being
best friends."
Upon its release in 1984, the original Terminator
film became an instant classic, cementing
Arnold Schwarzenegger as a movie star and
launching the career of director James Cameron.
The second film installment, 1991's Terminator
2: Judgment Day, was an even bigger success
than the first, thanks to its astounding visual
effects and exciting action sequences, even
winning multiple Academy Awards.
Viewers demanded more adventures within this
action-packed universe, and studio execs have
been only too happy to comply with an entire
franchise which has spanned decades and has
included sequels, comic books, and a television
series.
2015's Terminator Genisys was the fifth installment
in the series — meant as a "soft reboot,"
it featured Schwarzenegger's return to the
franchise.
What followed was some a poor box office performance
and a terrible reception from critics, and
its planned sequel was eventually canceled
— which definitely came as a relief to star
Emilia Clarke, best known as Daenerys Targaryen
on Game of Thrones.
In fact, Clarke later told Vanity Fair that
"no one had a good time," not even director
Alan Taylor (with whom Clarke frequently worked
on Thrones).
Based on an idea conceived by Will Smith,
After Earth told the tale of a father and
son in the distant future, played by Smith
and his real-life son Jaden.
The two characters spend their time leading
space expeditions to find inhabitable planets
and accidentally land on a damaged, dangerous
Earth.
As the two are separated and struggle to survive
on an unfamiliar and hostile plane, audiences
follow the journey of Jaden's character as
he struggles to reunite with his father.
Despite the stars' best efforts, the film
flopped at the box office and performed similarly
poorly with critics.
In the aftermath of After Earth, Smith admitted
that the film was was "the most painful failure"
of his career which is strong words for an
actor that starred in Wild, Wild West.
"When you're telling this story to your grandkids,
you make sure you leave this part out."
"Don't worry."
There was once a time when few actors would
even consider turning down an opportunity
to work with Woody Allen.
He's a multiple Academy Award-winner, and
movies like Annie Hall, Hannah and her Sisters,
and Crimes and Misdemeanors are widely viewed
as classics.
However, after his controversial marriage
to Soon-Yi Previn, the adopted daughter of
his former partner Mia Farrow, Allen's personal
life often took over headlines; in 2014, Dylan
Farrow, one of Mia Farrow's other adopted
children, repeated her allegations of sexual
abuse at the hands of the famous director.
With the rise of the #MeToo movement, Allen
became a public relations nightmare for the
actors and artists who chose to work with
him, and they started speaking out against
him in droves.
Two notable examples were Greta Gerwig and
Ellen Page, who appeared in 2012's To Rome
With Love.
Both actors have spoken out against everything
from gender inequality in film to their own
experiences with assault, and they didn't
mince words looking back on their time on
the set with Allen — Gerwig has said she
wouldn't work with the director again, while
Page called it the "biggest regret" of her
career.
Years before the Netflix television show,
there was another Daredevil live-action adaptation.
2003's Daredevil starred Ben Affleck as the
blind vigilante, and Jennifer Garner as Elektra,
another superhero and Daredevil's love interest.
On the villain side of things were Colin Farrell
as brutal assassin Bullseye, and Michael Clarke
Duncan as the vicious crime lord known as
Kingpin.
Though the film performed well at the box
office, it was panned by critics, and remains
an infamous example of one of the worst comic-to-film
adaptations in the modern era.
Affleck, whose career has seen plenty of highs
and lows, clearly agrees, as he admitted in
2013 that he "actually regrets" Daredevil
despite loving the character.
He cited that earlier failure as one moody
vigilante as the reason why he'd agree to
star as another—this time for DC as the
new Batman.
It's a little crazy to think that the actor
who also starred in Gigli could have an even
bigger regret, but clearly, Daredevil's botched
big-screen debut still weighs on Affleck.
Sometimes, a superhero movie can catapult
an actor to stardom even if they're already
well-known, like when Robert Downey Jr. breathed
new life into his career by stepping into
Tony Stark's Iron Man suit.
Other times, however, that same opportunity
can become an actor's biggest regret.
Even for an actor like George Clooney, who
seems impervious to professional misfortune,
a bad superhero film can become a blight on
any performer's career.
Clooney's time as the Caped Crusader in 1997's
Batman & Robin certainly proves it.
Directed by Joel Schumacher, it's become a
long-running joke, is routinely called one
of the worst films of all time, and is the
lowest-grossing live-action Batman movie to
date, shutting down the entire franchise until
its 2005 reboot, Batman Begins.
Clooney's career didn't suffer any serious
decline after Batman & Robin — he's won
two Academy Awards, become a lauded director,
and even received the AFI Lifetime Achievement
Award in 2018.
Still, he told Deadline in 2013 that he keeps
a photo of himself as Batman in his office
as a reminder of what happens when you make
a movie for purely commercial reasons.
As the self-made star of Rocky, Sylvester
Stallone had his pick of projects for years,
since he was known as an actor capable of
handling action scenes just as easily as serious,
dramatic moments.
Still, he was never exactly known for his
comedy, and he shocked audiences by taking
a light-hearted detour with 1992's Stop!
Or My Mom Will Shoot.
The film was an odd buddy-cop outing that
paired Stallone with Estelle Getty, best known
for her role as Sophia on The Golden Girls.
The two banded together as a mother and son
team to solve crimes — a flimsy premise
that was met with predictably terrible reviews.
The script for the film was infamously bad
— so bad that it was hard not to wonder
what Stallone saw in the project.
Arnold Schwarzenegger later took the blame,
admitting that he feigned an interest in starring
in the film to trick his action hero rival
into taking the role and harpooning his own
career.
For his part, Stallone has made it clear that
he's far from fond of this film, calling it
"the worst" of his career and admitting that
he regrets making it in the first place.
Released in 1993 and based on one of the most
popular video games of all time, Super Mario
Bros. set an unfortunate standard for video
game films.
The film was a complete failure both critically
and commercially, in large part thanks to
its flimsy plot and terrible writing.
However, the actors involved certainly weren't
terrible; Super Mario Bros. starred the late
Bob Hoskins as Mario and John Leguizamo as
his brother Luigi, with a plot revolving around
a scenario that mimicked the game — Mario
and Luigi had to find and rescue Princess
Peach from the evil King Koopa.
Hoskins, an accomplished and well-regarded
British actor best known for Mona Lisa and
Who Framed Roger Rabbit, has made no secret
of his disdain for the film — during a Q&A
in 2011, he made it clear that the project
was the biggest regret of his entire career.
To his credit, Leguizamo felt the same way,
but was kinder about it, praising the rest
of the cast and crew for doing their best
in a bad situation.
Stephenie Meyer's Twilight book series was
an immediate hit when the first installment
arrived on shelves in 2005.
The books tell the story of Bella Swan, a
normal teenager who unexpectedly falls in
love with a century-old vampire, Edward Cullen,
at her high school.
A film franchise followed in 2008 thanks to
overwhelming demand, with Kristen Stewart
as Bella and Robert Pattinson as Edward.
The series grossed nearly $3.3 billion at
the box office, creating a pop culture phenomenon
for years to come.
Still, throughout the series, the young actors
involved seemed displeased with their involvement,
and have treated their experience with the
saga with polite distaste in the intervening
years.
Pattinson was by far the most vocal about
his hatred for the series; over the years,
he's called Edward a prude, dissed Meyer's
ideas, and made it clear that he hated starring
in the movies more than anybody else involved.
"A lot of things in the Twilight world doesn't
make sense.
Why are they still going to high school?
They're 100 years old."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.